على الرئيس اردوغان
وبالتالي اثرت على عدد كبير جدا من
المواطنين ايضا هناك
تحركات من كل انحاء البلاد الى هذه
المنطقه طبعا هناك
ظروف طقس صعبه جدا وهناك صعوبات ميدانيه
بسبب
الدمار الذي حصل في هذه المنطقه ولكن
العمليات مستمره الى حد الان هناك خطوره
تسببت بها المباني
التي تاثرت من هذه
الزلازل ولكن رغم كل الشروط الصعبه
والظروف الصعبه نستخدم كل الامكانيات
الدوله
نقوم بمساعده
واعمال البحث والانقاذ
المواطنين العالقين تحت الانقاذ
العاملين في فرق الانقاذ تعمل الان وهناك
ايضا فرق اضافيه
تزداد بالعمل طبعا هذه الفرق تزداد كرقم
وتذكقه وعامله ايضا للانقاذ
وهناك عدد كبير ايضا من
المتضامنين في هذه العمليه طبعا هناك
مساعدات ايضا يتم تقديمها في هذا الصدد من
الطعام وجراب وايضا المساعده الاوليه
والمساعدات الطبيه والبطانيات وايضا
المساعدات الاخرى الى حد الان
[موسيقى]
تم انشاء 454 الف مخيم وارسالها الى هذه
المناطق وايضا
عدد كبير من المعدات الطبيه التي تم
ارسالها ايضا الى هناك طبعا هناك دعم
مستمر للاداريه للادارات المحليه وايضا تم
من المدن الاخرى تم ارسالهم الى هذه
المناطق هناك اعمال مستمره بشكل كثيف
لتقديم الدعم الى هذه المنطقه لاداره
الكارثه هناك ولتنسيق العمليات هناك طبعا
كل وزير في كل منطقه يتواجد لتنسيق لتنسيق
الجماعي لعمليات الانقاذ السيد فؤاد
يتواجد في مركز افاد وينسق عمليه الانقاذ
من هناك ونحن لدينا وزراء معنيين في كل
مدينه ونحن نتواصل معهم باستمرار من اجل
تقديم مساعده اللازمه وايضا من اجل متابعه
كل المستجدات لحظه بلحظه هناك مساعدات
طارئه نقوم بتقديمها وتملكه دعم نقوم
بتقديمه وبالتالي اولا
[موسيقى]
قمنا بتعيين 100 مليار ليره
مبلغ اولي لتقديم المساعدات اللازمه كخطوه
اولى هناك خطوط
الخطوط الهواتف الان
الهواتف النقاله الخطوط الهواتف النقاله
تعمل بشكل سليم وايضا تم ارسال
[موسيقى]
بعض المعدات الاضافيه والمتحركه الى مناطق
ولكن الى حد الان لدينا بعض الصعوبات في
الوصول الى مناطق الامداد والى مناطق
الانهيارات لذلك نحن نطالب بعدم استخدام
الطرق المؤديه الى هذه المناطق قدر
المستطاع وعدم القيام باتصالات هاتفيه من
اجل التقليل من الضغط على الخطوط الهاتفيه
هناك
بعض الطائرات للخطوط الجويه قمنا بتخصيصها
لنقل المساعدات هناك اكثر من 1000 سياره
اسعاف تم ارسالها الى هذه هناك ايضا
مروحيه اسعاف تم ارسالها وايضا 5000 موظف
وعامل في مجال الصحه تم ارسالهم الى هذه
المنطقه
ولدينا ايضا مشروع اخر العمل على
التبرع بالدم لابقاء مخزون الدم عالي قدر
المستطاع لتقديم المساعدات الطبيه ايضا في
هذا الصدد هناك
فرق البحث والانقاذ يعملون بالاضافه الى
القوات المسلحه التركيه والقوات الامن
وقوات الدرك وايضا القوات الداعمه وقوات
الدفاع المدنيه يتواجدون هناك تم زياده
ايضا عدد الفرق التي كانت متواجده في
انحاء تم ارسال عدد كبير منها الى هذه
المنطقه بالاضافه الى تخصيص
الطائره الطائرات التي تحمل المواد تم
تخصيصها
لنقل المساعدات الى هذه المنطقه طبعا
القوه ق وات الامن تتواجد بكل عناصرها
الان في المنطقه وقوات الدرك تتواجد هناك
ايضا مع القوات الخاصه كما انها خصصت عدد
كبير من طائراتها لنقل الشحن الى هذه
المنطقه بالاضافه الى وجود قوات خفر
السواحل ايضا في هذه المنطقه للمساهمه في
هذه العمليات
نعمل الان على التشخيص الدقيق لمدى انتشار
هذا الزلزال في المناطق وبالتالي خصصنا
المسيرات الان للتصوير من الاعلى من
خلالها نقوم على تشخيص المناطق التي
يتواجد فيها
المباني المنهاره وايضا
المصابين بهذه ازاله الان
تعمل كل
البلديات وتقوم كل البلديات بارسال من
انحاء البلاد تقوم البلديات بارسال
معداتها ومركباتها وكل وسيله يمكننا
استخدامها في هذا
التسخيرها لهذه
لعمليات البحث تقوم ببريات بارسالها دون
تمييز السياسي او تمييز توجهي في السياسه
لذلك نحن نشكر ايضا الجميع على هذه
الخطوات وعلى هذه المبادرات
نحن الان نستطيع ان نقول اننا نستطيع
اتخاذ او اننا
قمنا على استمرار هذه العمليات العمليات
البحث
مع الاسف تظهر مشاهد مؤلمه بسبب استمرار
البحث وهناك بعض
الزياده في عدد الوفيات في عمليات الانقاذ
حيث
اننا نرى
اننا نقوم بارسال ايضا المرض المصابين
والمرضى والجرحى الى مرسين والى اسطنبول
والى المدن الاخرى في هذه
المنطقه نتقدم بتعازينه
لشعب التركي ونتمنى الشفاء العاجل
للمصابين وللاشجرحى منذ يوم امس كما
تعلمون اننا
اعلنا الحداد وسيتم تنكيس الالام حتى ثاني
عشر من شهر
ابريل طبعا الى جانب ذلك نرى ان هناك
الكثير من المسؤوليات التي يتم اتخاذها
الان ونحن نشارك كل المعلومات
والمستجدات بسبب الزلزال وايضا تم تعطيل
المدارس الى شهر فبراير اعجبت هذا تم
تعطيل المدارس الى عشرين الى تاريخ 20
فبراير
في مناطق الزلزال وفي مناطق هذه
الاكارثه وتم التخصيص عدد كبير من المدارس
والمراكز الرياضيه والمراكز الثقافيه
الصحيه والسليمه
للنجينه من هذه
الزلازل
طبعا يتم التخطيط باستمرار للمئوي المؤقته
يتم العمل على تخصيص بعض الاسئله الاضافيه
مركز الرياضيه ايضا
لهذه
لتدخلها لمساعده الناجين منه هذا
الزلزال وطبعا هناك كما ذكرنا منطقه
انتشار واسعه جدا لازل وبالتالي هناك بعض
المشاكل في الوصول الى حد الان الى بعض
العالقين تحت الانقاض عدد
الوفيات قد وصل الى ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه
وتسعه واربعين
المواطن ولدينا
22,168
جريح ومصاب جراء هذا الزلزال ولكن الى
جانب كل هذه
الاخبار التي نقوم بنشرها او الى كل
مساعينا
لنشر الاخبار السابقه ولاخبار الجميع
بالمستجدات الحديثه ولكن هناك لحد الان
نرى اخبار كاذبه
ونحن الان ليس بوسعنا ان نرحق هذا وذاك
لاننا سخرنا كل امكانياتنا لتقديم
المساعدات ولعمليات الانقاذ والبحث عن
المواطنين العالقين تحت الانقاض ولكن فيما
بعد سنقوم بملاحقه كل من نشر هذه الاكاذيب
والاخبار المزيفه على موقع التواصل
الاجتماعي او هنا وهناك الان
هناك الكثير من القاده الادولين الذين
اتصلوا وكانوا على التواصل مستمر معي من
اجل الحصول على المسجدات الاخيره بهذه
الكارثه وايضا لتقديم وعروضهم لتقديم
المساعدات في خصوص البحث والانقاذ
للعالقين تحت الانقاذ نحن نقيم كل هذه
المبادرات والاتصالات ونشكر كل من ساهم في
تقديم هذه المساعدات ونشكر الجميع الذين
كل ما بوسعهم من اجل
عمليات الانقاذ والبحث طبعا هناك عدد كبير
ايضا من رجال الاعمال الذين عليهم ان
يتبرعوا
لاداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه والى اي
منظمات الاخرى من اجل استخدامها في
المساعدات ومن اجل تقديمها للمواطنين
المتضررين من هذه ازله طبعا هناك تفاقم في
نسبه
الاضرار التي نراها في هذه المدن المدن
العشره التي تاثرت من الزلازل الان هذه
المنطقه هي منطقه كوارث هي مناطق منكوبه
وتم اعلانها كمناطق من كوبا و سنستمر
بتسريع وتيره البحث والانقاذ وسنستخدم
الماده 119 للدستور ونعلن
لحاله الطوارئ في هذه المناطق
بسبب هذا الزلزال وهذه الحاله حاله
الطوارئ ستستمر لمده ثلاثه اشهر
وسيتم اكمالها اكمال هذه الفتره واكمال
القرارات المتعلقه بذلك في المجلس في
البرلمان التركي
نحن نعيش احد اكبر الكوارث العالميه الان
ونسخر كل امكانياتنا وخطوطنا من اجل
عمليات البحث والانقاذ ونتحرك بشكل سريع
ونرى ان هناك
كارثه كبيره وهناك ظروف جويه سيئه جدا
هناك ظروف الطقس صعبه للغايه وبالتالي نحن
لم نتمكن من التسارع في وتيره المساعدات
هذا ونحن على ونحن على درايه في ذلك نحن
نحاول ان نصل الى كل نقطه في المناطق
المتضرره ونعمل على تسهيل كل الطرق قصار
جهودنا للوصول الى هذه المناطق لدينا
الصعوبات وهناك تحديات كبيره جدا
وسنصل الى كل نقطه متضرره في هذه المنطقه
وسنستمر في العمل في هذه العمليات عمليات
الانقاذ وعمليات انتشال كل من بقي عالقا
تحت هذه الانقاد باذنه تعالى سنتغلب على
هذه الصعوبات ايضا
وسنتخلص من هذا الدمائر الشامل الذي حصل
في هذه المناطق الاولويه الان لتسريع
وسيره عمليات جهود الانقاذ وايضا ايصال
المساعدات الى المتضررين بهذا الزلزال
وبعد ذلك سنقوم رفع الانقاض واعاده
الاعمار كخطوه اخيره
ذلك
وفي هذه الاثناء
دوله قطر الان تستعد لارسال
عشر الاف حاويه الى تركيا وايضا هناك
مساعي وجهود لتقديم المساعدات الينا وعروض
لتقديم المساعدات الينا طبعا نحن الان
بحاجه الى كرفانات والى حاويات عدد كبير
منها يصل ولكن نحن بالمزيد بحاجه الى
المزيد من ذلك وسنقوم بتخصيصها الى
المواطنين المتضررين من هذا الزلزال
واشكركم